well i'm joined now by the chairman of
utility energy and the former chair of
the government committee on fuel poverty
derrick licorice uh mr licorice is it
not as simple as saying shouldn't the
energy companies take less profits
i understand the point that's being made
but we need to draw a distinction
between
what we mean by energy companies i mean
the energy retail companies like
ourselves utilita
uh octopus
eon all of those the retail sector is
overall is loss making and whilst it
would be very nice and i would love to
be in a situation of saying right we'll
just cut our prices
and uh to customers we're not in a
position to do that and i only wish we
were the amount we are allowed to charge
customers for
energy is set by
the price cap and of course the price
cap was designed a long time ago
and doesn't work particularly well when
we have volatility in the marketplace
and at the moment we have never ever
seen such volatility that we do as we
have today and if you recall the rishi
sunak announced
back in may may the 26th if i remember
correctly he announced that there would
be a lot of support for customers
overall and the one that would go to
everyone is 400 pounds
but at that time the price cap was going
to be around
2800 pounds and as we now know it's
going to be around 3
600 pounds so
400 pounds
he was going to give to everybody then
now needs another 800 pounds adding to
it so um i'm afraid the energy retailers
are certainly not in the position to
bridge any gap like that at all i only
wish we could
do you think the government then should
be doing that i mean i mean essentially
the amount that he promised needs to
double and and then some would would
that help would that make enough of a
difference um every little helps as as
it's as it's said but what we're facing
here is a crisis like we've never had
before in terms of energy prices and my
primary concern is for our customers and
for the poorest and most vulnerable
customers
that's why today i've been calling for a
social tariff and i appreciate sky news
giving me the opportunity to make that
point again
i i cannot believe that the government
appears to be sitting on its hands and
watching this tragedy unfold
because we have the the contest for the
leadership going on at the moment i
would have thought that those two
contestants
should be joining with the current prime
minister and sort out what they're going
to do to avert this problem for the
poorest and the most vulnerable and
that's why i would like to see the
industry pull together and put in place
by the first of january a social tariff
for the most vulnerable and i think that
that would involve somewhere around 10
million households
and those 10 million households if i can
just think about it for a minute and
draw this to retention this trust talks
a lot about tax cuts
well you have something like four and a
half million households live on less
than twelve thousand seven hundred and
fifty pounds a year that's that's all
they earn
so they don't pay any tax so tax cuts
won't help them
people who live on benefits alone tax
cuts won't help them so we have to be
bold we have to be brave and i think a
social tariff fixed at a price that
customers can afford
is the right solution to where we are
today then for the rest of us who won't
fall into that category
we will constantly need to be looking
at how people's incomes are going to be
topped up
but at the moment i cannot imagine what
it must be like
to be living on such a low income
already in debt as we've heard and we
also know that around four million of
the poorest households have other
arrears building up
our company we have a special team
called extra care
where we
get our customers who are in the most
difficulty
and those customers it tends to be no
money and my concern is we've seen 140
percent increase in our calls to that
part of our business
for people with no money and here we are
it's in the middle of summer
um if i can just share this with you
that in 2020
that if 50 pounds of energy
would have lasted you between 10 and 12
days
when the price cap comes in on the 1st
of october that's going to last you
three and a half days
and currently when the price cap goes up
again
on the 1st of january that 50 pounds of
energy is going to last you
2.8 days and that's providing the cap
doesn't go up anymore
it's not certain all these estimates
that we give i think we're getting
reasonably accurate now with the october
cap which will be around 3600 i do
believe that
but we are not sure about the price cap
in
december because we're still referencing
the tariff
and the the price cap tariff reference
period doesn't end until the middle of
november there is plenty of there's
plenty of opportunity for putin to cause
us more trouble squeeze gas and see
prices go even higher that's why we've
got to take action sorry i interrupted
you no no just say that that
the chancellor and business uh
and energy companies are meeting
tomorrow um
any hope that this will be
you know this is obviously something
that that will be on their radar any any
hope that this will be what will come
from that well we started this
conversation about this generic term
energy companies and i mentioned uh that
we are the energy retailers yes we are
an energy company but we are making we
are not profitable as such at present
there are other energy companies there
are people that of course who build wind
farms who have have received subsidies
for renewable schemes there are the oil
majors who are obviously drilling and
for
gas
and those are the companies that are in
at that meeting tomorrow so um
utilita is not at that meeting um
they will have heard today about what
some of us are asking for i hope it gets
discussed but i cannot see that being
concluded we do have several discussions
with government and with the regulator
and i for my part i will continue
my call for a social tariff
excuse me we're hearing about a cost of
living package as well being being put
together
again this is not going to be something
that that either of the uh prospective
tory leaders are going to be held to do
you have any confidence at all that will
make a difference
um
no i'm very concerned
and i think that the the government has
a duty of care
despite its current um situation with
the uh with the outgoing prime minister
but that shouldn't stop them getting
together and deciding and setting a
direction of travel so much ground work
needs to be done in anything that we do
and the sooner we start
with the groundworks of making sure we
can do what we think we can what i'm
saying we can do it needs that ignition
to that plan and that surely
can be given by trust sunac and boris
johnson
are you surprised that you the chairman
of a utility company find yourself in in
a position where you are essentially
trying to come up with social policy
to try to ease poverty for people
does it surprise me yes it does um i but
i have as you when you introduce me i
was the uh
government's chairman of the fuel
poverty advisory group for nearly seven
years and that's exactly what we were
trying to do and we did discuss a social
tariff back then but not in the heat of
the battle or the size of the issue that
we have today
and that's what annoys me even more that
um whilst we had the debates in the past
where the problems were nowhere near as
challenging as they are now i'm not
hearing it enough today with the sense
of urgency it needs because there's
going to be an interregnum as far as um
the the the government is concerned with
the um voting going on for our new
leader they need to give you
the government gets the the level of
concern and the impact that it is having
on people
i think some of them do i thought that
rishi sunak on talk tv last night
um has certainly got what we've been
trying to tell him for a long time so
he's caught up
this needs to be tightly targeted and
very deep to the poor that need it the
most
so um
to me it's palpably obvious what we need
to be doing and enough of us have got to
go and kick the backsides of those that
can do it and the sooner they do it then
i shall start resting a bit easier and i
hope more importantly so so with our
customers a third of our customers a
third of our customer base are on our
priority services register which means
that they have vulnerability issues of
some kind and i've listened into calls
to to hear of their plight and it is
heartbreaking and i come back this is
the summer
not the winter demand in the winter will
go through the roof and it'll be about
they'll be spending about 150 to 160
more this winter than they were last
winter so this is absolutely horrifying
where we're going where we're heading
for
okay derek licorice chairman of utilita
energy good to talk to you today thank
you thank you